and today would like to talk about uh
many folds meshes and geometric graphs
so this is maybe a little bit more
exotic i think in most computer science
programs
you uh usually don't encounter many
folds
so uh we'll try to convince you that
these are interesting objects and
they're worthwhile to to be normal and
to be studied
so um
this was uh just to
a reminder for you
um a reminder for you what kind of
domains we considered so far so we
talked about the 5g of geometric
depending and today we're talking the
the last g so we're talking about uh
manifolds meshes and geometric crafts
and taco after me we'll be talking about
uh gauges which is uh a generalization
for manifolds so what is called bundles
so um i remind you also that we could
define different popular architectures
as instances of the geometric deep
running blueprint by choosing the domain
and the symmetry group
and for example in convolutional neural
networks the domain was agreed and the
symmetry group was a translation group
we for example we talked about graph
neural networks right or or deep sets
where the domain was a graph or a set
and the symmetry group was permutation
so here we are talking about uh
intrinsic or mesh cnns the domain will
be some discretization of a manifold
typically a measure or maybe a geometric
graph and we'll see that we actually
have two different types of symmetries
or in variances one of them is global so
we're talking about isometries with
respect to some deformations and another
one will be local so this will be what
taco then will expand on will be called
engaged symmetries
so maybe first of all why it all uh
manifolds are interesting so these are
as i said a little bit exotic of an
object
in machine learning
so when we deal with problems in
computer vision and computer graphics
we are trying to describe
three-dimensional objects so
three-dimensional objects in many cases
you can describe them as volumes right
as shown on the left here so
basically instead of pixels you have
voxels
and
in this case if you are not interested
in what happens inside the object if you
are interested just in the outside
[Music]
there is some
some disturbance maybe you can turn off
your audio uh uh then we can model it
sorry benjamin i think uh
thank you
so an alternative to modeling the the
volumetric representation of the object
we can think of a two-dimensional
surface that the the boundary surface of
the object and this is
a two-dimensional manifold right that is
typically discretized as a mesh
and as a result we have a significantly
less wasteful representation
so uh when we are talking about
deformable objects uh like the human
body for example or facial expressions
so then we can use um techniques from
differential geometry that allows very
nature to think of deformations and
describe deformations of many folds
now in other applications that we will
also see in our guest talk when modeling
proteins
so proteins are large molecules that
that interact with each other and with
with other molecules in our body
and the way that they interact they
present to the outside world what is
called the molecular surface so we don't
really care about to a large extent at
least what happens inside how
intricately the protein is folded
so a way to abstract out this internal
folding is to represent them as surfaces
and again because they change their
conformation when they interact it is
important to be able to treat these
these objects appropriately so the two
types of environments that i mentioned
as we'll see so if we have a manifold
we'll uh need to work with it locally so
first type of invariance will be the the
ambiguity in the change of the or in the
choice of the local system of
coordinates that that's what we'll call
the gauge
the second type of symmetry is global
it's a deformation for example when we
deform one shape into another uh we can
slightly stretch or bend it locally and
we want to be invariant to these kind of
deformations or at least approximately
environment
now
what we've seen before for example when
we take the grids as example right so
convolution in the plane the way that
that we worked and the way that for
example convolutional neural networks
work so we have some local filter that
we move around our image
and we correlate this filter with the
content of the image in different
locations
so uh what allows us to do it is the
fact that we can move the filter
globally so we have some global
representation of of our space and the
group that attacks globally so we can
move
this local representation of the filter
anywhere in the image this is typically
not the case in differential geometry
when we have a general manifold then the
the
the way that that our filter will move
will depend on the path we go so if in
the plane it doesn't matter which way i
go on for example a sphere it will
matter and we can also have some exotic
uh cases such as the the non-orientable
manifolds the mobius surface in which
case uh i will not only have a different
rotation but i can also have a flip
of the chord date so i have a reflection
i change the handedness instead of
left-handed or right-handed system of
coordinates i get the opposite one
so there are several recipes how we can
generalize the idea of this local
filtering or convolution type
of
of architectures to non-euclidean
domains so we can for example say that
we fix the path so there is a kind of
canonical path between two different
points we'll call it the geodesic so i
can go along a certain path i can fix
the gauge so i can say that i don't have
any ambiguity in my system of
coordinates because i pre-computed we
will see that it's in principle possible
but it
arrives it rises certain difficulties
we can also say that okay if i have an
ambiguity such as rotation let's
do a form of pulling over all possible
rotations
then if again i have ambiguity of
rotations i can say that they have a
filter that is isotropic so it's
rotationally environment and then it
doesn't matter how i rotate the local
frame and finally and this is what taco
will be describing in his next lecture
we can have a filter that is gauge
equivalent so it will change in the same
way as uh if i change the system of
coordinates
okay so i will focus mainly on these
three possibilities of uh
fixed gauge group pulling and isotropic
filters but before that we'll need to
get some background about differential
geometry and basically we need to
discuss three things so first of all how
to define local stuff on many forms
right so what i said that that we have a
local filter that that in the euclidean
case right on the grid we just extract a
block of pixels from the image and we
multiply them by
by some some mask so this is uh
significantly more elaborate on the
manifold so we will need to understand
what is a remaining metric and a
probably exponential map in order to do
it second question is how to move things
around so we'll need to understand about
uh parallel transport how i move
things uh for example how i move a
vector on the manifold such that it is
uh i preserve the angle
and then we'll talk about uh symmetries
and environments that are related to
manifolds and again the local version of
it
will be discussed in the next lecture
so here is a crash course on manifolds
so what are manifold so uh it's good to
imagine something like the sphere or
maybe this kind of two-dimensional blob
okay so these are technically speaking
are topological spaces so the difference
between topology and geometry roughly is
that we have the notion of neighborhood
but you don't have the notion of
distance so i can tell for my neighbors
but i can i don't have the
the uh the notion of how far they are
right so i don't have the notion of a
distance and i don't have the notion of
angles so i don't have inner products so
it is a very basic thing basically
topology operates with
a concept of open sets
okay what is a smooth manifold basically
we have small transitions between what
is called local charts right and i have
uh basically a manifold is a topological
space that is locally equivalent to the
eulerian space right this is what we
call homeomorphic so an s dimensional
manifold is locally homomorphic to an s
dimensional equilibrium space and since
in most cases we'll be talking about
surfaces so these are two dimensional
manifolds and there are locally
topologically equivalent or homeomorphic
to a plane okay and this is what we call
the tangent space or the tangent plane
uh it is you can think of it as attached
to every point and we call it the
tangent bundle collection of all the
tangent spaces so again some
technical subtleties so this is what is
called a disjoint union so we consider
the same spaces uh differently if
they're attached to different points
okay so bottom line we can
represent
the manifold the space around every
point but we don't have a global
representation for it right so we can
work in the tangent space uh only
locally
so in the tangent space we have tangent
vectors so i denote them by capital
letters x
and they model um kind of local
displacement right so we'll we can then
identify them with directional
derivatives what is important to
understand about vectors in geometry in
general is that they are coordinate free
right so these are abstract geometric
structures and uh i don't know how uh
you
were thought about vectors but often uh
you say you're said that a vector is an
arrow right you can think of it as a
kind of an arrow or you can think of it
as a kind of array of numbers so both
views are incorrect technically speaking
because vectors are just abstract things
and the only thing that you can do with
them you can add them and you can
multiply them by scalar and they satisfy
a set of rules so that's how you define
a vector space
in order to think of a vector as
an arrow you need an extra notion that
is called the inner product and then
you're talking about a space with a
vector space in a paragraph it's called
the hilbert space right so this is what
gives you a notion of direction
in order to talk about vectors as array
of numbers you need coordinates so you
need some bases
with respect to which you can represent
the vectors
and this is the local basis so a choice
of s in this case in our in this figure
two vectors
uh that are not collinear so they're
linearly independent and they span the
tangent space and they can represent
with respect to these vectors any vector
in the tangent space by projecting them
on
x1 and x2
and this is what we'll call a gauge so
basically the collection of these local
bases
that depends smoothly on the position so
if i move from point u to a point nearby
this
choice of
basis factors will not change abruptly
okay so this is just a fancy name used
in physics for this
collection of local reference frames and
what the gauge allows us to do with a
vector is exactly represented as an
array of coordinates so i will denote
these the array of coordinates that
coordinate the representation of a
vector by small a bold letter x
okay
now the the the the fact that we
consider so far manifold as a
topological object means that
uh it's a kind of uh very uh flexible
infinitely flexible rubber object right
and there is this joke about apologies
breakfast
that they can have coffee from a mug and
then deform it continuously into a
taurus into a donut and then eat it
right so this means that we don't have
really any notion of uh
any notion of geometry on these objects
so we need to equip
our manifold with geometry and this is
done uh through the notion that is
called the romanian magic so remaining
magic is just a local inner product at
every dungeon space at every point right
so it's typically denoted by g or just
inner product with sub index u and it
allows us to locally measure uh angle
length and area right so the angle is
just given as the the
arc cosine of the inner product between
two tangent vectors the length will be
just the norm in used by this inner
product and the area that we can measure
it is the determinant of this uh of this
quadratic form g so i can express it as
a matrix with respect to subsystem of
coordinates and the determinant is
coordinate independent
and we call
quantities or
properties that are expressible entirely
in terms of the remaining magic
intrinsic so once i have defined a magic
on the manifold
then
if i
do something to this manifold
and the magic doesn't change
then
everything that is expressed in the
metric also in terms of the magic also
doesn't change so intrinsic properties
are very important because they're
invariant to certain types of
deformations that we will call
isometries
so another important notion is the
notion of geodesics so if i have two
points on the manifold let's call the
medium u and v
i can define a curve so i parametrize it
over some interval between zero and t
capital
uh that goes from point u to point v
okay and the at time t so think of it as
time so think of it as some kind of car
that drives
at from point u to point field so at
time
zero at the starting it's at point q and
the time t
that that has uh that has taken to drive
there it gets to point v okay
so we assume that the curve is smooth
right so everything is differentiable we
can uh talk about the tangent or
velocity vector as the derivative of
this uh of this curve with respect to
the parameter t right
and uh basically at every point it
belongs
to the tangent space at the relevant
point right so if i'm now at point t
then the velocity will be a tangent
vector in this space of that in the
tangent space at that point
so how can we measure the length of the
curve i can just break it into these
small intervals and sum them up right so
if i take the limit then we get integral
over the the
the length or right or the norm of the
velocity vectors and a reminder that the
norm is given by the demanding magic
and if we integrate it between zero and
t right with respect to the time
parameter we get the length of the curve
and geodesic is simply a length
minimizing curve so out of all the
possible
smooth curves that connect to points u
and v the one that is the shortest
will be
the geonysic
so
what is important to know about
geodesics is that
they are
intrinsic
so they
are defined
through the remaining metric right and
you can see it here in the definition so
uh if i if i change the manifold in a
way that doesn't change statement or
metric you can see from this formula
that the length of the curve will not it
will not change
now given this we can also define a
geodetic distance so i simply say that
the way of measuring the distance
between two points will be just build a
geodesic between them and measure its
lengths
so there is a question about how can we
determine the direction of any point
on the manifold so it's not the
direction of a point it's a direction of
a vector right
and uh the direction is relative so if i
have two vectors in the tangent plane i
can measure the angle between them using
the remaining magic right using my inner
product so that's
that's how it's determined
okay but we don't have a global
direction uh so this is not something
that that that that is that is defined
so remaining magic acts only locally
okay so here is a little bit confusing
uh a little bit confusing um
uh choice of terminology is that
distances are often also called metrics
right so there is a branch of geometry
that is called magic geometry that
operates with generalization of
distances that are called metrics so in
order not to confuse the two terms
because we also called a magic this
bilinear quadratic form that
the inner product on the manifold so i
will prefer to use the term distance
okay so geodesic distance again is
a way of measuring the distance between
any two points on the manifold and it
will be just given as the length of the
geodesic collecting them what is
important to understand that not always
in general as you can you can assume in
mathematics it doesn't uh
it's not taken for granted that certain
thing exists right so when we write a
minimum it doesn't mean that the minimum
exists so you can find examples of
spaces where the minimum is never
achieved right
so uh we can show that that if the
manifold is connected
then in other words you cannot
represent it as uh
as the two coverings that are disjoined
it
we can achieve the minimum of a geodesic
and then we call such uh magic space
complete
so completeness technically speaking
means that every cochise sequence
converges right and we'll see that that
in romanian geometry there are several
equivalent the definition of
completeness
okay what is also important on december
geodesic distances are intrinsic so
again if i bend the manifold without
changing the remaining metric then
the geologic distances will not change
and an important result called the
hopfreeno theorem
makes
establishes the equivalence between
magic completeness in other words that
every cauchy sequence converges in this
uh magic space
and uh geodesic completeness which means
that i can shoot the geodesic from every
any point in any interaction and follow
it indefinitely so i can
create a path and follow
for it until i'm tired
now um what another thing that geodesics
allow us to do is to define what is
called the parallel transport so it's a
way of moving a vector from point u to
point v right so let's say that i have
this vector x at point u right so it's a
tangent vector
in the respective tangent space
i can define a geodesic that goes from u
to v right with these endpoints and now
i can define a family of vectors i
denote them x t right so they're
parameterized by this curve by the
geodesic
and i want that along this curve
the length of the vector is constant
right so that's measured by the
remaining magic and then the angle
between the vector
and the tangent to the curve the
velocity vector is also constant so in
other words i'm moving
two vectors such that the angle between
them is preserved so if this is
satisfied we say that x
is parallel transported along the curve
okay
so there is a
question here
why uh you define the inner product on
gamma t instead of
t of gamma t yeah so this is just a
notation right so we said that we define
the inner product at some point right
and it's an inner product on the tangent
space at that point
so it's just to say that the inner
product that is on the tangent space at
that point and gamma t is a point on the
manifold right so it's a point on the
curve
okay so this is this was just a notation
right and parallel transport uh it is
also called the connection basically
it's this map between two dungeon spaces
tangent space at point q and tangent
space at point v
and basically it's a mechanism to
transport vectors between dungeon spaces
it is also intrinsic so we i can express
it in terms of remaining and magic only
this is how i defined it and uh it
amounts to rotation on the manifold with
the metric
the
basically what happens to the vector
right because we said that the the
length of the vector is preserved i have
a mechanism to measure it
what happens to the vector is rotation
right so this map just rotates the
vector when i move it from one dungeon
space to another right so it's an
element of the special orthogonal group
so i should also say that connection is
more general
than what i described here
we can define it absolutely without
resorting to romanian metric through
what is called the covariant derivative
so therefore uh you can have multiple
connections defined on many faults but
there is a special one that is called
the leviticus connection that distortion
free and compatible with the remaining
magic so if i define
basically i can define a connection
manifold without any remainder magic but
if i give you a manifold with the
remaining magic remaining manifold then
there is a unique connection that is a
special one that is the leviticus the
connection so in our case because we are
talking about many remaining manifolds
uh we will be assuming if we are talking
about connection right or parallel
transport then it will be this special
one okay but allow me not to go into
details what is meant by torsion
so another important concept is
exponential map
uh and uh basically it's a way of
mapping locally around point uh u2 to um
to the manifold right basically the way
that i can do it is if i have a point u
i can always define a geodesic that
starts
at point u
in some direction right so i can you can
give me a vector x and i can define a
curve for which the the tangent vector
at uh
at point zero will coincide with x okay
and uh i can follow these geodesic
and uh
when this uh these geodesic is defined
for any t right from zero to infinity
this is what is what we call geodesic
completeness right so i can follow this
uh this path indefinitely
and the exponential map
is
defined by taking
a unit step along the geodesic in
certain direction right so geodesic
exponential map takes us from the
tangent space so it takes a unit vector
defines the geodesic in this direction
and takes a unique step along this
geodesic and it lends us to a point on a
minifold okay
so that's uh
that's what exponential map does so
basically what it allows us is a lot it
allows us to work
on the tangent plane
but to go into fetch values of something
from the manifold right as we'll see
this will be very handy when we for
example wants to define a local filter i
will need to use the exponential map to
bring the values of the function defined
on the manifold and then uh
then now i work in the plane right or in
the in the euclidean space where it's
much more convenient
so uh as a
before it is also intrinsic
now what uh the subtle point is that
geodesic completely doesn't guarantee
that
the the exponential map is a global
different morphes in other words it's a
differentiable bijective map with
differentiable inverse so we might have
some disasters like is shown here so if
i extend it too much then there will be
it will not be smooth it will be
differentiable and the largest radius
for which
uh this map is differmorphic is called
the injectivity radius so it might be
different at every point and usually
injectivity radius of the manifold is
the smallest one across all the points
so this is
all you need to know about
manifolds about differential geometry so
let's now see how we use it uh to define
something similar to convolution okay
so
we'll assume that we have some signal on
the manifold right so it's a function
defined at every point so let's say
scalar function
and we define a filter that i denote by
like by psi like before in the tangent
space okay
so uh conceptually what will be the
analogy of spatial convolution
is that i take the integral
of the filter right
and i integrate on the tangent space at
every point
with the values of the function that i
bring to this tangent space through the
exponential map okay so i compose here
the the signal with exponential map so
it allows me to take
a vector
in the tangent space and it will
correspond to the value of the function
right so it gives me a local view on the
function around the point q right so
this is how it looks like
and then i just correlate it with the
filter that i define in this space and
they get an analogy of convolution
the problem here of course is that
these are abstract geometric vectors
right so i don't really have a way of
computing this integral in order to do
it i need to define a gauge right so i
need to represent vectors as array of
coordinates so i can uh deal with them
on the computer
and
this implies that i need to define a
local gauge so a local system of
coordinates and the problem is that
these gauges arbitrary right i can
define it in many different ways
so i need to say that the convolution
here depends on the choice of the gauge
and if i change the gauge you will get a
different result right so if i
rotate for example my local system of
coordinates
then uh the result of this uh of this
integration
will be different
so
the question is how can these gauge
transform right so what is our ambiguity
so if we just have a naked manifold so
to say so just a topological object then
any change of coordinates by an
invertible matrix what is called the
general linear group is allowed right so
i don't have really any other structure
so what they need to
to
to ensure that that is not degenerate
otherwise any
linear transformation is possible so any
invertible matrix
if i have an orientable manifold then i
can talk about what is called gl plus
and these are invertible matrices with
positive determinant if i have a
manifold with a volume form right so i
you need to understand that these
notions are independent of the metric
right so you can define a volume volume
form separately from from any romanian
structure then we're talking about
matrices with determinant equal to one
right so determinant can be thought of
as a representation of the volume
if i have a manifold with the metric
then i have
an ocean of direction right so we can
talk about
uh we can restrict our ambiguity to
orthogonal matrices that preserve
directions now orthogonal matrices can
still flip
the orientation right and uh this is
what exactly what happens on
surfaces such as the the mobius
surface
where which is not orientable
so if i have many fold that has magic
and orientation that i can i can also
restrict these matrices to have
determinant one right so they preserve
uh they preserve orientation and uh we
are talking about the special orthogonal
group and finally if you have a manifold
with a frame field then there is no
ambiguity so this
gauge is prescribed exactly
and here you can see
a visualization of um of these
ambiguities so uh this is a rotation
ambiguity i can choose
uh engage and i can rotate the arbitrary
at every point what is important
differently at every point
if i have uh for example the mobius
strip so it looks like the plane but the
only thing that that changes here is
that when i move from one point to
another i can flip
the system of coordinates and then when
i have a fixed gauge like on the sphere
for example we have some canonical way
of choosing coordinates
then uh
there is no ambiguity whatsoever
okay so in practical situations we deal
with these two settings so we have
either a
fold with the frame filled we'll talk
about it in a second or we have uh the
the so3 or sois or so2
ambiguity so local
orientation preserving rotations
so here as i said we have
uh several possibilities so we can fix
the gauge we can do uh crop pulling we
can do isotropic filters
and we can do gauge equivalent filters
okay so the first thing is let's try to
fix a gauge so there are actually
techniques how to do it so you can take
for example an intrinsic function
and compute an intrinsic gradient of it
we'll talk about it in a second and this
gives you
a set of vectors
that are
uh
smooth
but they can also be uh they can also
vanish in a few points
so if you are happy with the vectors
vanishing at a few points
then this is a valid this is a valid
solution
okay and um
another possibility is to have an
angular pooling so let's say that we use
polar coordinates to define our filter
in the tangent space in the tangent
plane
so here we can say that i don't know how
to orient the filter so let's look at
all the possible orientations
and uh correlate the filter with uh
basically rotated versions of the filter
with my function
and then take the maximum right so it's
kind of correlation with the rotating
mask
so uh of course
uh this way i
throw away some information we can also
have isotropic filters so isotropic
filter means that now the filter is
rotationally symmetric so it depends on
the radius not on the angle and in this
case
i don't need to do what i have to do
previously right but i lose
discriminating discriminative power
so the filter is the filter is symmetric
now
let's talk about deformation and
variance
and uh this is what we have achieved so
far right so we have a filter that is
defined intrinsically on the manifold
and if i deform the manifold
then
i uh
i don't suffer
any deformations if this deformation is
such that it doesn't change the romanian
magic right
what we will call an isometry so we can
think of domain deformation as a map
between two different manifolds right so
we have a manifold omega we have another
manifold omega wave and i have a map
let's call it eta from omega to omega
wave right
now
what is important to understand is what
i need to
i will need to describe now is how it
changes the remaining metric right
and usually you would just say that okay
if i have a point i have infinitesimal
displacement from this point
i i can also make an infinite
displacement from the image of the
function
right and this is what is called the
differential
so the analogy of this is called the
push forward map so the analogy of
differential in in remaining geometry is
a map between two dungeon spaces
remember that we said that the tangent
vectors are a model of local
displacement so that's exactly it so if
i uh if i'm at point u
and i make a displacement by a vector x
then i can tell you how this
displacement will affect the uh will be
mapped by under the map eta
by this uh
uh by this function that i call this
push forward right the eta
that maps me to another tangent space on
the manifold omega
wave around the point at the u right the
image of this point on the atom
and uh
this tells me how exactly i
changed so i can define the opposite so
if i can define the pullback so the
pullback tells me
basically how the metric will be
affected and this is called the pullback
matrix so i can take i can measure the
distances
right locally or i can measure inner
products
on the my original manifold right in the
dungeon space
around point u by going to the other
manifold right by means of eta
uh
taking the magic from there and defining
a new metric on my original main fault
right you see it
so there is a question do we have a
guarantee on manifolds uniformity
because the way we compute the geodesic
sure this curve assumes the transition
between
all the points
is the same so i'm not sure that i
understand
this question so the transition is
defined by the remaining magic
so any notion of length or direction is
defined by the remaining metric and we
are assuming that this is these are
differentiable manifolds so we can make
basically we can write limits right so
we can take infinitesimal steps so all
is properly defined
right so but back to the the concept of
pullback uh i hope you can understand
this right so this is what is denoted by
by uh eta star h
so h is uh the magic on my second
manifold on omega wave so i take tangent
vectors right so magic takes a pair of
100 factors x and y
i map them by they push forward
to the to the other manifold i take the
metric of that other manifold and this
gives me a magic on the original
minifigure right so this is called the
magic pullback and if this uh
if these two metrics coincide right so
if i
uh the magic that is given by pullback
on the new manifold coincides with the
original one that i denoted by g
for every point then we're talking about
uh
a map that is an isometry right so
technically it's a different morpheme
between remaining manifolds such that
the pullback metric
is equal to the original one right so
it's a map that preserves remaining
magic
so another way of defining a zombie
isometry in a different sense is i can
say that i have
two uh points u and v
they will be mapped to some other points
n of u and f of
right i have the geodesic distances that
i define right on each manifold so dg
and the h
and if these distances are preserved
right
then i can talk about what we will call
a metric iso machine
okay so basically it's a map now between
matrix spaces
and if this composition is preserved for
every pair of points then we are talking
about metric base of which okay so one
follows automatic from another right so
because we define geodesics as intrinsic
so the
romanian isometry preserves
uh uh preserves uh distances as a result
remaining iso which is uh uh necessary
isometries and there is a theorem in
differential geometry that says that on
connected manifolds the two are
equivalent right so there is a single
concept of isometry so if i preserve
remaining metric or preserve the
geodesic distances
the the
two are equivalent okay
and this allows us to talk about what we
didn't discuss we i think we briefly
alluded to in uh in juan's lecture
uh
signal deformation versus the main
deformation right so i remind you that
what we want for example when we talked
about the variance we said that
if i have
a function that operates on signals on
some domain right
if i transform this signal by some group
uh and the result of the function
doesn't change then we're talking about
grouping variance right
so again the operation here was on
signals on a domain
so here we are in a different situation
we have a domain deformation right so we
have our domain that we deformed from
omega we now went to omega wave
and we want to make sure that
the function that is computed now on
this new domain on the signal on the new
domain will be the same right so that's
exactly what i showed in this slide
before
this kind of situation right so uh when
i have some filter that is defined in
this domain and you see that the
deformation doesn't change the result of
this filtering so that's exactly what i
mean by
uh by domain deformation now same way as
we had some uh relaxed notion of this
right so we could say that that
uh if i have approximate invariance we
could measure how far
this deformation is from a group and we
can bound the change in the value of the
function right so that was crucial for
convolutional neural networks for
example we can also do something similar
for the domain deformation so for
example i can say how far am i from an
isometry for example by measuring the
metric distortion and this way i can say
that that my function is approximately
isometric environment so all these
constructions that i described before
will be environment under isometric
deformations and approximately
environment under approximate
resolutions
okay any questions so far
okay
so if there are no questions let's talk
about uh the
uh spectral
approach to manifolds how to define the
frequency form so we we talked about
fourier transforms talking about crits
so let's talk about the generalization
of it right and this will be related to
easy rocket filtering
so i remind you that in the euclidean
case
uh when we define convolution we modeled
it uh as a circular matrix that acts on
a domain with on a grid with periodic
boundary conditions and we've seen that
convolutions or circular matrices
commute
and commuting matrices are jointly
diagonalizable in the sense you can
roughly say that they have the same
eigenvectors and then they can pick up
one of the conversions the shift
operator and compute this eigenvectors
that happen to be the discrete fourier
transforms and you get that convolutions
are diagonalized by the frequencies form
okay
now we can pick up here any matrix so
for example instead of the shift
operator you could pick up the laplacian
operation so on the grid it looks like
this right so this is second order
derivative its eigenvectors are all will
also be the dft and then again we get
the same result
so
what we see is that that fourier basis
functions right so they're laplacian
eigen functions it's also very easy to
verify that a two-dimensional the
one-dimensional plus an operator is just
second-order derivative so if i take
second-order derivative of the
exponential i get back the exponential
scaled by the frequency squared right
so this is the eigenvalue and this is
the eigenfunction we can also interpret
the fourier basis as orthogonal basis
that minimizes the division energy so
the actual energy will be the norm of
the gradient of the function it tells us
how smooth
the signal is so we can interpret the
fourier basis as the smoothest
orthogonal basis with respect to this
with respect to this
function
you can also interpret
it as local difference from your
neighbors right so if you write
the uh this discrete version of
laplacian agreed right so it will be the
sum of the
two neighbors minus twice
the the neighbor in the middle right so
if up to normalization right if you
divide everything by two this will be
how different you are from the average
of your neighbors
so we would like to define something
similar on manifolds and for this
purpose we'll need uh the notions of uh
differential operations on many folds so
let's first define a scar of field right
so scholar field is just a real function
that is defined in the meaningful so to
every point i attach some value right so
think of temperature of uh some surface
okay so i will denote this space by
calligraphic x of omega r
okay what is a vector field so it's uh a
function that takes us from every point
uh on the manifolds to the tangent space
right or the tangent bundle so at every
point it assigns a tangent vector at the
corresponding tangent tangent space at
that point
okay
what is the point to apply for a
transform to a metaphor okay good
question so we don't apply the free
transform to the manifold we will apply
for your transforms to signals on
defaults
the point i can already anticipate is
that once you do the fourier
decomposition you can forget about the
many folder you can work with the
fourier coefficients so that's the power
of the free analysis that you can
abstract out completely the underlying
domain okay so basically
you have a basis in which you can
represent signals
okay we'll get to it in a second
okay so these are vector fields and you
can think of vector fields as a kind of
local displacement displacement or flow
of things on the meaningful right so you
can think of flow of particles flow of
temperature
now we can equip these spaces with inner
products right so again these are not
inner products
like we've seen before
on tangent vectors so these are inner
products between functions right
so uh the way that i do inner product
between two scholar functions is just
multiply them point wise and then
integrate okay and this integral is
defined so i need to define what is d u
so the u is given by the the volume
element on the manifold and usually you
can just take it from the
from the remaining metric that will be
the exactly the determinant of that
magic that you've seen before
now for uh vector fields the way that i
define the inner product is i take the
uh
the local inner product using the
remaining metric right for every point
these are tangent vectors
uh at t u right
and i can take the uh the inner product
between them right and this is scalar so
then i integrate it on the entire
manifold and i get a number right so
this is how i take inner products
between scalar fields and vector fields
so i will use exactly the same notation
so it will be clear from the context
on what
kind of data this inner product is
applied okay
so what is an intrinsic gradient so uh
if i stand at the point right and i have
values of a function
on the manifold i am interested in the
following question what is the direction
of the steepest increase
of the function at point u
okay
something that we are keenly interested
in in many applications right well for
example we do some optimization
so we need for this purpose to define a
directional derivative right so what is
the directional derivative
so directional derivative will tell you
that uh
if i move
in the direction y
what will be the value of the function
as a result of this move right so
it's exactly given by the differential
that we defined before right so it's a
map between two manifolds the the
manifold one is omega the other metaphor
this is r
right so it's a trivial one so it tells
us how
the the function will change if i make a
displacement in the fraction y right at
every point
so it is a linear functional right
now you need to understand that that
linear functionals on vectors are what
is called dual vectors right
so it's uh something that takes a vector
and gives you a number
right and the vector here is y
and the number is
how much the function has changed again
i remind you that we cannot say uh x of
u plus d u right because this u plus du
is not defined so we need to work with
these local displacements with
differentials defined slightly more
complicated than in the euclidean space
okay
now we know from uh uh
from functional analysis that
every dual vector
has uh every presentation as a vector
this is called the least representation
theorem so basically every linear
function on vectors can be written like
this as an inner product right and the
inner product here is the remaining
metric because we are talking about
vectors in the tangent space about
tangent vectors so i can write uh the it
is functional
as an inner product of y with something
with another vector so this vector is
called the gradient
right so that's actually the correct way
of thinking of the gradient so usually
you say that the gradient is the the the
the vector uh basically an array of uh
partial derivatives of function so this
is not correct definition of the
gradient the gradient
is a representation of a linear
functional that's called the
differential
that
is coordinate dependent right so if you
write it in a certain system of
coordinates then indeed you can write it
as an array of partial derivatives of
the function okay but it's an abstract
vector it's an abstract notion so that's
what we call a nabla of x at point u
right
now what is an intrinsic gradient when
we apply it to the vector field at every
point
so this will be a vector field right so
it's an operator that takes us from
scholar fields to vector fields
and it tells us
what is the steepest increase at every
point of this scour field okay
so basically i start with a scour field
and i get into a vector field and every
point it points in the direction of the
steepest steepest increase of this color
field
so the divergence is the opposite so
it's an operator that turns vector
fields into scalar fields and we can
think of it as a flow
of the field for infinitesimal mode okay
so how much comes in and how much comes
out
and uh you can also define right or you
can think of it either as a property or
as a definition that the these two
operators the versions and the gradient
are a joint
a joint means that if i take an inner
product between the vector field x right
and here the inner product will be on
vector fields and the gradient of its
color field x lower case
then it will be equal to the divergence
of the vector field inner product with
the scatter field x lower case right and
the inner product here is on scar fields
right
so uh
basically
divergence is the adjoint operator
of the gradient
okay
now we can also define the laplacian or
the laplace build transparent as it's
called in differential geometry so it's
an operator that takes color fields and
speeds out scalar fields
uh you can think of it as a local
difference between the function the
point and its average neighbor the
neighborhood value on some infinitesimal
ball right now this is typically not how
you are used to the opposite right so
plus and for example in 2d is the sum of
two-dimensional partial derivatives
and what you get automatically from this
definition that it should be rotation
invariant right
so it doesn't matter if i rotate the
system of coordinates
i uh i will get the same value right so
this is not obvious from uh uh
d squared
uh uh x with respect to d u1 squared
right plus the squared x with respect to
du2 squared right the second order
derivative with respect to the to both
coordinates of the function so actually
prove it
that
you have this rotational symmetry it's
not difficult
okay what what else do we know about the
possible primary operator is that it's
intrinsic and it is self-adjoint so in
other words it's symmetric so basically
you can write it as inner product of
two gradients right so inner product i
should say on the one vector fields
uh which will be equal right because of
the joint property i can move the uh
i can move the gradient to the right
hand side right and it becomes a network
of scholar fields and the divergence of
the gradient is exactly how we defined
the laplace of the possible jumbo
creature so this is how it's defined and
because of its self-adjointness it will
have real liking values which is
important we can regard them as
frequencies the analogy of frequencies
in the fourier transform
so the operator is
named after pierre simon laplace and
eugenio beltrami so beltrami was early
italian differential geometry that
generalized
this operator to local coordinates in
non-euclidean spaces
now
the laplacian is really ubiquitous you
will find it everywhere in physics
and one example where it appears
prominently is in
heat equations
so heat equations were studied heat
diffusion was studied as early as by sir
isaac newton
more than
300 years ago
and he came up with the law that is
called the newton law of cooling that
tells you that the rate of change of a
temperature of an object is proportional
to the difference in the temperatures
between the object and its environment
right
so uh the diffusion equation is a
differential version of this law of
cooling so on the left-hand side x is
the temperature right so it's a scalar
field
uh on the left-hand side we have the
rate of change right so how much it
changes instantaneously in time
the on the right hand side you have the
laplacian which measures the difference
between the
the temperature at the point and its
environment
and
the diffusion diffusivity coefficient is
some proportional coefficient
right so here is another equation where
it appears is the wave equation
so that was formulated by french
motivation mathematician the lumber
and basically what it tells is that
you have um
you can
you can think of a wave as a system of
masses connected by springs right so the
tiny invitational masses connected by
tiny infinitesimal springs so the
acceleration
uh equals
to from from newton's law we know uh
equals to the the force
attacks on these masses
right and uh
the acceleration will be second order
derivative so that will be the
displacement of the masses
and the force here is the local elastic
force this is hooke's law
so
again given by the by the
in this case by one dimensional plasma
so um this is what you see
this is where you see that
the laplacian uh the lassen appear in
mathematical physics another experiment
that you can do so i'm not sure you will
hear the sound but basically here is a
plate with a thin layer of sand on it
and if you apply vibrations of different
frequencies
you see that at some frequencies certain
patterns will be forming
so this was an experiment that was first
done by a german physicist called aaron
squadly
in the 18th century and basically he
took
he tried to visualize how different uh
instruments sound why for example
violin sounds better than a cheap violin
that you buy four hundred dollars in in
in
in a violin shop
so uh he put this uh layer of sand and
applied vibrations to the plate right to
the deck of the
of the violin uh by passing a bow on it
and he observed and drew these kind of
patterns that were forming now at that
time he didn't have a clue
why actually this this happens or he
made these
experimental visualizations and he
actually toured the the courts of of
europe and even
napoleon himself was so impressed that
he offered a monetary reward for one who
would be able to explain
why this phenomenon happened so now of
course we have an explanation so
we if we look at the wave equation
as we that we've seen before right so
this is what governs the the vibrations
of the plate so the way that we solve a
wave equation is by separation of
variables so we have a two-dimensional
function of position and time right so
let's say it's one dimensional broad
that it vibrates so i can separate
the solution into a product of the
spatial part and the temporal part the
denoted by phi and tau
and if i plug it into the equation this
is what i get right
so i can rearrange it and i get
uh the
ratio of uh the derivative of tau over
tau and the ratio of the derivative of
phi
over phi so this must be equal for every
t and u so it means that it's constant
and let's call this constant lambda
and you see that the spatial part of the
solution
are laplacian eigen functions right so i
get the laplacian of phi equals lambda
phi so this is what is called in physics
the helmholtz equation and we can
interpret the phi's as vibration modes
and lambdas the vibration frequencies so
these are these are exactly
uh they're the kind of
the patterns that you observed in the
the in cloudness experiment
so uh the zero crossings
of the eigen functions is where the the
send doesn't jump right so where it
stays fixed
and uh this is what he observed it was
the the the zero level set or the zero
crossings of the eigenfunctions of the
laplacian
of that domain and the frequencies that
the at which these patterns were formed
are exactly lambdas the corresponding
eigenvalues of this of this operator
now i can compute the laplacian on on
many folds in this way right so we
cannot put send
on uh on for example the human shape
right because gravity will just let it
fall back but we can do the same
experiment computation so we can compute
these these uh eigenfunctions
and uh laplacian laplacian operation on
a compact manifold has countable eigen
decomposition so the eigenvalues are
discrete
and uh this is how they look like so the
cool and hot colors represent negative
and positive values so the first
eigenvector is constant right like the
the zero frequency the dc what is called
uh in the free infrared analysis and
then the first eigenvector is called the
fetal vector so it tells you the kind of
largest variation direction on a
manifold and then as you go into higher
frequencies then the oscillations right
so how these eigen functions change from
positive to negative values will
increase
what is important is that these eigen
functions are
intrinsic as a result they're isometric
environments so if i bend this human
nothing will change right so the
eigenfunctions will look the same
and we can define an analogy of the
fourier transform that i can call a
manifold fourier transform by just
taking the inner products of scar by
scalar field x with these eigen
functions so these are given functions
are also scholar fields right so these
inner products give us the fourier
coefficients right or the fourier
transform so this this is the analogy of
fourier series and the inverse fourier
transform because it's an orthogonal
basis we just take
these coefficients and we sum up the the
basis functions with these coefficients
we get back
the signal okay
so it allows us to decompose scalar
fields in some orthogonal basis
and we can work now with the
coefficients so basically we forget
about the meaningful right so i get i
work with these numbers with x k hat i
don't know what is omega here i don't
care what is omega here right so
somebody asked
why we need to define the the fourier
transform on the minifield exactly
because of this reason now i can
completely abstract out what is omega
what is the domain on which i defined it
as long as i have a way of defining the
laplacian on this domain net performance
eigen composition i can forget now
completely about this domain
now what you also see that unlike uh for
example the two-dimensional frequency
form we have only one dimensional
frequency here lambda right so we can
order the eigenvalues for example in
increasing order we don't have
two-dimensional or three-dimensional
frequencies so we don't have a notion of
direction
okay
and we can define an analogy of
convolution that is typically called
spectral convolution by using what is a
property of classical free transforms as
a definition so remember that we could
define uh convolution by taking the
product pointwise product products
frequency-wise products of the fourier
transforms on the grid
so here we can define our fourier
transform as i take the products of the
fourier coefficients of my signal and my
filter
right and i take
uh
now i these are the new weighting
coefficients by which i write the
eigenfunctions and i
sum them up right so this weighted
combination will give me some signal on
the manifold okay
so there are several drawbacks first of
all we've seen that we have a fast way
of doing
the fragrance form
on on grids because we have different
types of fast-free transforms so here we
don't have these possibilities so we
need to multiply
by basically project on the matrix of
eigenvectors that is usually a dense
matrix so it incurs n
squared complexity
so another thing that we see is that the
filter will not be localized and second
thing the third thing is that the
filters will be isotropic right because
we don't have a notion of directional
frequency so the filter will look like
this concentric creeks essentially
and uh we know that it will be isometry
environment right so as we change the
manifold
deform the manifold asymmetrically uh we
expect the coefficients to be the same
right and i get functions to be the same
but in practice it is unstable because
uh
we don't really have uh
exact isometries so even slight changes
in the pass and when a ghost right in
the composition will result in
significant perturbations of the
eigenvectors and a good visualization is
this so we have a domain right so in
this case it's a manifold representing a
horse
we have a signal that looks like these
blobs
and
let's say that i do some kind of filter
so the filter here does some form of
edge detection so i can write it
as a spectral filter so we have some
coefficients
these these are the three coefficients
of the signal x and these are the the
the eigenvectors okay
now
imagine that what i will do is i will
use
the
i will deform the domain and i will use
exactly the same coefficients right that
they denoted by alpha coefficients of
the filter on the new fourier
coefficients of the signal that will be
obtained in this new bases and you see
that it's the result looks completely
differently
so because the deformation of the domain
is not an exact isometric and especially
at high frequencies i will get uh
differently
looking eigenvectors and this result
i will have two bases that are different
than the the three coefficients so to
say don't speak the same language
so i cannot apply simply the filter from
one domain to another domain
so what we can do we can do something
different we can say that
i can represent my filter as a kind of
transfer function
that i apply to the plus and operation
and the way to apply a function to an
operator is to uh apply it to its
eigenvalues right so that's exactly what
i do so now i have the fourier transform
of the signal and i apply
the uh
the transfer function to the to the
eigenvalues and this is my filter okay
and it's a one-dimensional function that
will look like something like this right
so it might be a low pass filter or
maybe a high pass filter or maybe some
some other function and uh
this way i get something that is stable
right
so you can see here so this will be this
function that is
localized around the point on the course
and you can see that when the course is
deformed then uh this
and this function follows the
deformation of the surface so no
disasters happen
now uh let's uh write it
slightly differently
so i can write the inner product right
so the inner product is an integral
with respect to v
of the signal
x and the the eigen function phi k
so i just change the
position of the summation and the
integration and assuming that this is
possible right so it is possible
when i use the right type of integration
label integration i can exchange uh
infinite summation and
and the integral
and what i see here is some function
that depends on two coordinates u and v
right and this is what we call
the heat kernel
typically
so it's kernel that is position
dependent right so you can think of it
as a kind of
spatially
uh
trying convolutional field right so in
convolution
this thing will not depend on the
coordinates it will depend on the second
coordinate it will depend on the
difference of the coordinates right so
on general manifold we don't have any
valid way of defining the notion of
difference between u and v so we have a
function of u and v right
so let's just make a scenic check how it
will look like in the elliott case so in
the equilibrium case
our
basis functions will be just complex
exponentials right so because they're
complex also in the inner product we
need to conjugate one of them so that's
why one of them will come with plus
and because
exponentials are associative i can write
it as exponential of u minus v so that's
where the uh
the standard euclidean case the
convolution
is a function of the difference between
the two points and not of the two points
right so this this kernel
is the same at every point
okay
any questions so far
so if there are no questions let's talk
about discretization so we talked about
so far about surfaces so the typical way
of discretizing them is using meshes so
measures you can think of them as a kind
of
graphs on steroids uh
so the question is how do we determine
the transfer function
so that's exactly what you learned so
you need to parameterize it in some way
so for example it can be polynomial
uh i will talk about it in a second
and the coefficients of these of this
polynomial are the lower number
parameters
so can the steepest increase also be
interpreted as the steepest decrease for
intrinsic gradient so the steepest
decrease is minus the gradient right so
the opposite direction
so what is the link between convolution
and the fourier transform so here there
is no obvious link between spatial
convolution as we defined it before
and the uh
and the conversion that that the
spectral convolution we defined
now so it only appears when you use
isotropic filters okay so we can
we can uh we'll talk about it again in a
second when we talk about
spectral
graph conversion networks okay
any further questions
okay so i see that i'm slightly over
time so let me try to rush through the
discretization of manifolds so we
discretize them as measures so
a mesh
basically this is what is called the
simplicial complex
so graphs are simply a complex they have
uh
they have synthesis of dimensions zero
which are nodes synthesis of dimension
1 which are edges
meshes have also simplices of dimension
1 which are triangles triangular faces
so
this is how they are defined and in
particular we are interested in what is
called manifold meshes so many fold
meshes must be
this case version of a manifold so the
manifoldness
means that each edge is shared by
exactly two triangular faces
right and
the boundary of all triangles incident
of each node forms a single group
so i cannot have this kind of examples
as shown on the right
okay so
the example of the horse here that is
shown is an example of a discrete
manifold or manifold mesh
okay so with every point of
with every node in this mesh i can
associate
some uh
coordinates in r3 so this is called an
embedding so it's a geometric
realization of the manifold otherwise a
mesh like a graph is a purely
topological object we can define the
discrete matching so i can measure just
using the ingredient distance the length
of every edge in the mesh right and this
will be a discrete magic
and anything that is expressible in
terms of this discrete magic is called
intrinsic so if i deform the mesh in a
way that
that this length is preserved then
i'm talking about isometric deformations
okay now in practice measures appear to
be rigid
so any deformation
usually we don't have a continuous
deformation that preserves the metric so
that's why it's extremely important to
have the notion of approximate
resolutions in these cases
so what is a discrete laplacian so the
discrete laplacian uh is uh looks like
this so i uh at every point
i look at my neighbors right so i have a
node u in the mesh
i have a neighbor v
and i
look at the difference between u and v
weighted by some coefficients and you
can see that
what it tells you is that it's some kind
of difference between the
node itself and the weighted average of
the neighbors right so it's exactly the
same interpretation as we had before so
it's how different am i from my
neighbors
i can write it as an n by n matrix
that looks like this so the matrix d is
the degree matrix and w is the weight
matrix so exactly as we've seen in the
graph
okay and typically it's sparse
with order of number of edges and four
meshes usually the number of ages is
bounded the degree of the nodes is
bounded so it's roughly as the number of
nodes the number of non-zeros in this
matrix
so there are several ways of defining a
plus laplacian operations on meshes
the most common that is used in computer
graphics is what is called the cotangent
for cotangent formula it goes back to
the 40s
and
this indifferent discrete differential
geometry was introduced by
pink allen poltier and by uh
uh
and
schroeder and debran
in the late 90s or 2000 early 2000s and
basically what it tells the quadrangle
formula tells you that the way that you
compute these coefficients w will be by
averaging the cotangent of the angles
that are
opposite to the h
u
right and you divide by the area
area element that is formed by
this
polygon that is that is constructed upon
the very centers of the triangles around
the point q okay
so this is how you compute these
coefficients now it's not obvious from
here that it's intrinsic but you can
rewrite it uh in this way so you can
express the coefficients
using uh the
length of the
of the edges
and you can also express
the areas
of the triangles using a heron semi
perimeter formula so the bottom line
this is all expressible in terms of the
discrete magic the h length and
therefore intrinsic
so we can also ignore the faces and
discretize the mesh as a graph right so
i just have my neighbors i have just the
edges and you can see that that here
i get more or less the same thing right
so the laplacian
looks like this so i have the degree of
x right if these are just combinatorial
combinatorial plus and then i just have
a one
as the weight of the h u and v
and we have the sum
of the neighbors so again
so this is a weighted combination so
it's the the feature vector of the node
right multiplied by the degree minus
the sum of the feature vector of the
neighbors so we've seen this already in
graphical networks so it's a linear
local
permutation environment aggregator right
that operates on the multi-set of my
neighbors right and the feature vector
itself
and uh it it produces a node-wise
permutation equivalent linear function
right so if i multiply
my
coordinates right
that are arranged into a matrix x by the
laplacian i will get this linear
function at this permutation equivalent
if i permute the rows of this matrix
the results will be promoted as well
right so it's a particular case of what
we've seen in graphing all networks with
better
now spectral cnns essentially operate
like this
so uh they apply
some function to the plus and then
operates on some signal defined on the
nodes of the mesh or graph
and
the precursors of these methods actually
come from discrete geometry processing
uh as early as the works of forgable
gabriel taubin from the 90s or the
famous work of zahikardi and craig
gotzman from thousands about spectral
measure compression
and graph signal processing so i feel
that emerged in the
harmonic analysis community
uh notably the the groups of pierre van
der geins and jose moura
in the beginning of 2010.
now the first uh construction of a
spectrographed neural network was done
by johann
in uh
2014 in their iclear paper where they
applied essentially the graph fourier
transform which is constructed exactly
as they did on many folds
and this was one of the
papers that revived the interesting
graphical networks that were defined
before but it suffered from high
complexity and stable and instabilities
under perturbations
um so the question is why do we need uh
the laplacian uh in the case of measures
so this is a way so measures the
discretization of a menu right so i
defined our plus on the manifold and uh
i discretize the manifold as a mesh so
the discrete version of the plus and or
the plus build random operator is the
mesh laplacian
which is a special form of the graphical
plus and right where these coefficients
are computed according some function all
of these both the mesh laplacian and the
graph laplacian are special cases of
these aggregation that we've seen in
graphical networks okay
so in order to deal with this
instability that we've seen before
with the example of the course uh
polynomial spectral filters were uh
proposed so that was the the chebnet and
the work of mikhail de ferrar uh xavier
bryson and pierre van der gries
that applies polynomial filters to the
plusen
and some other functions of course are
possible so we had a work that we called
kylie net which uses rational spectral
filters and also some stability results
including the work of
a student who now became a professor at
a definite wrong levy
with whom i worked
that proved that such filters are stable
so
again let me recap how we do
spectral filtering on a graph
or on a mesh right so it's more or less
the same
so
on an undirected graph the graph will
pass and is symmetric matrix that that
has orthogonal organic composition so i
can take this matrix and decompose into
eigenvectors phi that are orthogonal and
a diagonal matrix values lambda okay so
the graph fourier transform will be just
multiplying by the the matrix phi
transposed so phi contains as columns
the basis vectors it incurs n squared
complexity inverse fourier transform is
uh multiplication by the inverse matrix
right the transpose of phi again n
squared complexity and then spectral
convolution will be just a product
of the fourier transform of the filter
and the signal and usually we design the
filter in the frequency domain and the
frequency
in the first space so it will be
basically
uh a multiplication by uh
by phi
of the product right so the inverse
fourier transform of the product of
differential forms
now
what chebyshevnet does is applies a
polynomial filter to the graph of
passing right so the graph applying the
filter to laplacian i remind you it
incurs
applying this function to the
eigenvalues and basically what
what it amounts to
is to take the powers of the laplacian
and multiply them by some coefficients
that are learnable right that we denote
here by alpha and sum everything up
so you see that we can avoid explicit
eigen decomposition whatsoever right i
don't really need to compute these phase
multiplied by the phi they just need to
take the powers of the laplace
so what does it take to compute the
power of the opposing if i have a
polynomial of degree r so i need to
multiply by
a sparse matrix r times so it's order of
the number of edges right on or on the
mesh it will be order of
uh of n approximately
it is stable under graph deformations
again i mentioned these results you can
look up
so we can show that if the the mesh is
deformed a little bit
then the result will be stable
and basically you can see that even
though we started as a spectral filter
right that operates on like values of
the plus and it boils down to simple
local averaging right so laplacian what
it does as we've seen it just averages
your neighbors so you applied this
averaging several times to the neighbors
of the neighbors so basically what you
get here is the convolutional flavor of
a graphical network
okay
so that's how we close the loop so we
started with
we started with
with spatial convolutions then we said
that we have
the ambiguity
of the local
choice of the gauge so we could use
isotropic filters that come from
spectral decomposition and indeed we see
that that applying spectral filters
spectral convolution
boils down to
isotropic filters in space
so i will stop here
please let me know if you have any
questions and then with taco you will be
talking about the more general
construction of gauge equivalent filters